non mais il faut qu des rendez vous
sportifs des temps c'est franchement
auquel j'étais parce que le rendez vous
programmé pour ce rendez-vous de castet
couilles
[Musique]
à la craie qui autant merci mon benjamin
qui sera avec nous demain d'hayange au
sein de l'équipe sera mon chéri très
bien alors greg guillotin ont déjà je
peux faire un petit préambule je viens
sur effet laissé de m'avoir recruté
parce que c'est vraiment un excellent
choix
voilà ce que l'année dernière chanter
que l'émission bat est un peu de lest à
s'essouffler et le voilà en fait là on
va donner un petit vent frais que ces
messages en aparté la dose de peps en
fait il a été comme ça et que benjamin
castaldi tout linkers exactement en fait
on a un pied j'ai plusieurs chroniqueurs
de l'émission oui grâce à lionel en fait
on collègues c'est ça qui leur a dit
faut que vous rencontriez un mec de
youtube qui s'appelle grec guillotin et
qui va nous aider à gérer l'image de
l'émission sur le web cette année est
donc en fait je me suis fait passer pour
un mec qui avaient un boulot énorme et
qu'il aura dit voilà ce qui va pas dans
ta carrière comment tu vas voir je gagne
c'est eh bien moi je vais gérer un peu
ton ta carrière parce que tu es un peu
dans le coup dans le creux de la vague
première partie l'idée est qu'en dise et
lionel effectivement ces jeunes filer un
coup de main à cyril pour rendre service
aujourd'hui vous êtes nombreux à vous
être dans le coup c'est pour ça que moi
en tant que star d'internet
il m'a dit voilà j'aimerais que tu ne
viennes nous nous prodiguer un peu tes
conseils parce que certains à dire pour
un peu peine à voir
je comprends rien du tout les gars c'est
bien ce que vous faites c'est pas bien
ce que vous faites s'il y en a un qui me
déplaît qui me déplaît je sors de
l'émission et toi aujourd'hui si je te
vois c'est que je considère côté sauvage
après tu dois connaître un peu les
grandes phases de ma carrière j'ai dû
voir pas mal ma tête elle est commentée
du tout bon je te situes vitré moi je
cartonne sur internet comme j'ai pu le
faire au cours de ma carrière
l'idée c'est que toi tu fasses aussi les
bons choix d'abord parce qu'il va pas
dans ta carrière deuxième temps on va
voir ce que je peux apporter et
troisième temps des propositions
concrètes de choses de projets digitaux
qu'on va exploser moi aujourd'hui je
suis ici pour donner un coup de pinceau
à vos carrières s'il ya des carrières
boiteuse je peux aider mais c'est pas
pour autant que j'ai retapé la maison
entière soit si la maison est en ruine
et tu vas quand lionel il me parle de
toi je me documente jouer sur wiki et je
me dis ok castard hockey
le mec il est défraîchie
avec deux trois coups de pinceaux avec
mon ex est bon on peut peut-être faire
quelque chose pour lui m6 loft et où sa
carte
tf1 est ok là tu vas casta il fait ses
preuves et après nrj 12 et bouquet final
equidia et là je me dis what the fuck me
rapprocher de ma famille il ya des f1 et
à equidia juste prend juste la mesure de
la situation et des pannes étaient ou
pas vieux palais soit games et pas autre
chose et des choix qu'il ya parce que
j'aime les chevaux étaient d'accord
qu'on voit quand même un quelqu'un qui
dégringole au fur et à mesure et puis
d'acheter chez les ados les dépenses
quitte tf1 c'est un choix délibéré
nous on est là qu une ferme de secret
story ouais c'est pas qu'elle y crois tu
vas c'est ça que je veux dire allez
arrêtez bush pédiatre été très bon la
pratique mais je pense qu'on a les deux
jeunes et patrimoine moi je t'aime
beaucoup mais tu peux m'expliquer
déclaré j'espère que je connais par
coeur
tiens beaucoup à notre connaissance que
j'avais fait déjà baver tout à fait bien
avant d'évoquer quoi je dirais pas qu'il
est au rendez vous et on doit dépenser
les rendez vous depuis des temps c'est
franchement auquel j'étais presque le
rendez vous politique la croissance
prévue de castet couilles devant lui et
j'ai un calme ne faut pas non plus trop
de casse et
bercy va bien merci monsieur venir non
après après l'attaqué pas versé bon mike
[Musique]